we bring your boy elon starr link i know
you and elias
yeah yeah yeah we're good friends he i
was talking to him the other day yeah he
loves your your commentary yeah like
when his baby mama came on the show
rhymes dude
that didn't happen that caused a little
i saw did that was a little issue i
don't i mean i'm sure he knows who i am
but i don't think he's too fond of me
regardless really
what i [ __ ] rip into him all the time
he sucks
but wait why does he suck
he is like the perfect definition of a
[ __ ] con man i'm supposed to love
everything he does normally and you're
supposed to like he's he's literally in
the renewable energy space he's doing
space exploration love those things
right but he is such a [ __ ] rugged
capitalist con man
that has been able to like use uh energy
credits to his advantage every single
industry that he's in suspiciously only
operates off of government subsidies
okay this is i think uh
reasonable criticism yeah can you
explain the energy credit thing i think
a lot of people don't understand how
in order
within a capitalist framework in order
for us to try to uh reduce our carbon
emissions our output
what we try to do is incentivize
companies with tax breaks or direct
dollars these are car companies yeah car
companies and every company has uh some
kind of you can buy energy credits for
him even if you're not a um well our
manufacturer car manufacturers do this
uh with the energy swap but um
other companies do this too like
landowners do this for example john
oliver had like a big uh uh takedown on
this uh thing that people do usually
well they'll be like this is
underdeveloped or undeveloped land and
we're offsetting carbon by not using
this land give us money yeah yeah so
that is of course isn't it yeah
and this is this is what's happening
essentially like so you yeah the
government stipulates how many
like what your energy output has to be
for your company for the amount of cars
you're putting out so if you are not
making a fleet of evs right and like
you're using yeah and reducing your your
uh you know carbon carbon producing
cars
then you can go and like
uh every one of his cars is not
producing any carbon exactly now he has
an excess of energy credits so for gm
and all these other companies they go to
essentially buy his energy credits
exactly and some might say that that is
why tesla is so profitable no that
literally is the reason i don't know the
economics of it so i can't that is
mainly the reason especially because
like he has done brilliant though he's
done the same [ __ ] over and over again
where he'll just be like we're gonna do
battery swaps never happens but it
doesn't matter because the stock price
reflects like what he says is what he
said is gonna happen yeah yeah uh tesla
is not a car manufacturer it's a
technology company which is why it's
like uh valued at like fifteen one
instead of yeah that's right yeah tech
uh valuations have a higher valuation
yeah yeah and and you know everyone
wants to be in on the unicorn so like
everyone is invested in it and it's it
becomes this like too big to fail scam
basically yeah because if we're all
invested in your success and my savings
are investing your success the last
thing i think this is why we feel like
the stock market was floated a little
bit when the pandemic came because it's
like if i'm all in baby yeah no that's
that's how it works uh they actually
privatized uh what was otherwise known
as like pensions and social security uh
through 401ks so even if you're [ __ ]
working in a kitchen or some [ __ ] even
if you're a chef in your upper middle
class you think you have an ownership
stake in the stock market because when
the stock market is doing well uh you
feel like you're doing well even if it's
like [ __ ] marginal yeah but when the
stock market is doing poorly those
losses are socialized so you're
definitely [ __ ] if the stock market is
doing poorly that's why everyone feels
like invested in it despite the fact
that ninety percent of the wealth in the
stock market is owned by the top ten
percent of wealth yeah which is [ __ ]
nuts and if you're a [ __ ] chef you're
not in the top ten percent of wealth
brother isn't that the case with all
wealth though isn't like ninety percent
of wealth always held the top ten
percent or the you know jordan peterson
paredo principle what is that he says it
all the time the 20 or the 80 20 the 80
20 rule the burrito principle twenty
percent of people make eighty percent of
the things yeah or is the output is like
dictated by twenty percent of the people
yeah right the top uh creators and
that's not necessarily that bad you're
you're saying that as long as the people
that are helping the creation of that
are getting paid yeah a reasonable wage
yeah reasonable wage and have like some
control over their lives you know what i
mean i don't do you get does anybody
look at you and be like i don't want
that i don't think this is a very
unreasonable argument small business
owners all the way to [ __ ] you know
ceos and [ __ ] don't like they would
literally go i don't believe that
someone should have some control of
their lives and if you've already if
you're if you ever got brainwashed into
[ __ ] going to college and like
reading an econ textbook
the textbook literally tells you what
i'm saying is wrong
it's just wrong completely wrong the
market decides what a fair wage is the
market doesn't at all account for human
nature economics doesn't i mean anytime
you talk to an econ guy he doesn't ever
seem to account for human nature yeah
they're
human beings they just think like oh
it's a widget factory [ __ ] who's
making the widgets you know what i mean
a guy is making the widgets you know
what you know what i think also like uh
manipulates reaction to this is like
when you're in
a creative field
there's a heightened value on creativity
right and especially with the people
that are working right here like every
idea is very important so we can come to
the best idea right so you want to
compensate creativity as much as you can
i think when you're so far removed from
the thing you're creating like the guy
who makes the widget you've never had a
conversation with him before you're like
well what does he need to make
what's the profitable thing you're
actually not valuing his creativity
because you're like i created the thing
you're just screwing it in or putting it
together that's like that that is that
is what happens in an increasingly
financialized economy
like the guy who's never stepped foot on
the factory floor has the ownership
stake yeah and has to say or he has even
delegated the management
responsibilities over to a board that
has a fiduciary responsibility to the
shareholders yeah the entire complex
system is built in a way where profit
uh which is uh you know extracted wages
like the additional compensation that
you would normally get yeah that you're
getting cut out of yeah uh and all
control over your life as well all
autonomy in your life uh taken away from
you stripped away from you is is
designed in a way to
yield this kind of uh
outcome but haven't you seen recently
like um
the fact that like people can work from
home now right yeah like my wife just
went to business school she's working
her job her job says you only have to
come in two days a week right and they
didn't say it because that's what they
want they said because the workers are
like i don't want to go back in five
years a week yeah [ __ ] that and then the
great resignation is the whole trend of
people just being like oh quiet yeah the
quiet residence and then now quiet
quitting is another way i quit
increasing literally just like which is
literally just like your work yeah this
is hilarious
so so great resignation first was a
bunch of people like oh i hate this
[ __ ] job i'm out and now there's
something called quiet quitting where
employees are basically like hey i'm not
going to go above and beyond what you've
asked me to do and employees employers
are like oh you're quiet that's called
quiet quitting and they're like no no no
i'm not quitting i'm just not going to
kill myself for this yeah
why would
that's insane it's just and that came as
a consequence of a little bit of of uh a
tight labor market creating conditions
that genuinely are supposed to happen
all the time which has never happened
before because labor had no power
explain tight labor market a tight labor
market is when there is uh an
unemployment rate that is
uh so low that uh there aren't enough
they're not workers there aren't enough
workers for the jobs okay so now now the
uh
and that's bad the power is in the hands
of the workers all of a sudden exactly
you have to stay home through normal
econ conditions when workers have more
of a bargaining power yeah they can just
say all right well you know if i quit
you're [ __ ] yeah right um what are you
gonna do you can't you can't fill this
role that's a strike essentially yeah
and and exactly but that has not
happened uh in the past
because well two different reasons one
is because there's always an
undocumented immigrant pool of labor
that american the american industry
especially like agricultural industries
take advantage of have always relied on
to be like okay you're not gonna do it
doesn't matter i'm not even hiring you
i'm hiring the guy that just came in
from guatemala and if he ever talks back
i could just call the ins or now ice on
them get another guatemalan immediately
yeah and then go and do that which by
the way purdue for example the chicken
factories yeah they do this this is a
part of this is built into their profit
margin it's calling ice on yeah
yeah and the government doesn't punish
you severely enough for undocumented
immigrants so you can just take an l one
time refuse to give them back pay and if
they ever ask for back pay boom call ice
on them pay the fine and then go back to
the [ __ ] exact same neighborhoods
that you have created
right and bust together into those
neighborhoods and and have a steady pool
of new workers that are desperate for a
job there's a uh
my my wife was telling me about the
they're developing programs that will
track keystrokes on your laptop on your
work laptop oh my god so this is this is
fascinating what workers thought was a
blessing which is i get to stay home i
do my laundry when i want i'll sneak a
workout in what i want to do but i'm
going to get my work done as long as i'm
getting my work done the the corporation
is happy we're happy i have a much more
happy lifestyle everybody's good and now
they're starting to calculate keystrokes
so they can tell if you're using your
work laptop or not and how many hours
you are using so while you're typing and
what you're searching so now there are
programs that move your mouse
like
automatically so it looks like you're
doing something so this is oh real quick
real quick just to this point so so i
guess what i'm saying is like what what
they thought was going to be an
advantage
now has allowed the corporations to spy
more even more intently if you're at
work they know you're there so like okay
we don't need to look over their
shoulder every single second yeah but
they've developed software to be on you
every single time al's point there will
immediately be somebody who's like
here's a workaround right like
but not everyone has access to that
workaround and knowledge of of using
that workaround
um but what you are describing is
basically something that karl marx uh
understood [ __ ] 200 years ago yeah
who's he the it's just a bearded dude
wrote some texts
yeah yeah he was he was a poster yeah
yeah he's a big poster yeah dirty
schlubby guy with the mustache
[Laughter]
but like it's
you have to always squeeze out as much
profit as you possibly can and profit is
uh making sure that your workforce is
working as efficiently as possible so
that is another way to surveil their
efficiency yeah to ensure that they're
[ __ ] working because god forbid now
the irony of course is that a lot of
these office jobs as we all know if
you've ever worked in this workforce
like if you're not in the service
industry especially like i did a job
like that you know i did biz dev right
and it's like
you're not working eight hours that's
crazy yeah you you could literally bang
out you could [ __ ] snore some
adderall yeah it literally banged that
[ __ ] out in like maximum an hour and 30
to two hours yeah and then the rest is
just like hanging out by the cooler yeah
um so that's how it used to work back in
the day but
now i feel like they are going to try
and and squeeze eight hours monitor yeah
and try to get eight hours of [ __ ]
work out which is insane but all matter
of technological improvements without
any sort of labor power ends up [ __ ]
over that i remember from the communist
manifesto is technology invariably hurts
the proletariat and makes it bourgeoisie
more money that was the thing that
really blew my mind because technology
like artificial intelligence and
automation right that's a beautiful
thing we're all on board with it
someone's got to [ __ ] clean the
toilets hopefully it's a robot and not a
human being right it takes you out
whatever human beings however the way it
works is because of the way that our
economy is organized right now when
there's any kind of automation they use
that to reduce redundancy so they will
fire someone so instead of like having
someone literally do like three hours of
work yeah for the same amount of pay now
they [ __ ] fired that guy and loaded
the rest of the work uh load onto one
guy who will do eight hours of work now
um and and have a higher output because
there's tech available and then what do
all the other people do that are fired
they start a podcast yeah
that's how it works and that's how we
are right what is the solution though
because there's no i can't imagine a
business owner honestly doing it any
other way yeah because why would they do
it any other way because everyone is
trained and conditioned into thinking
this is the right way to do it
which i personally believe is not the
right way to do it so there are multiple
different methods of ensuring this
the immediate thing you can do is
unionization obviously